joining me now is Minority Leader Kevin
McCarthy all right congressman I I just
have to say I wasn't surprised by this
at all but it seems like your censure
resolution was well-founded what's your
reaction to the latest news New York
Times broken well if you watch the
Democrats are trying to discredit
democracy this is a simple exactly what
it is and we should go further than
censure he should be removed from the
chairmanship of the Intel committee and
one person makes that decision the
Speaker of the House I requested that in
March because let's walk through this
two years ago he lied to the American
public where he said he had proof and
evidence beyond circumstantial and
carried us through this nightmare for
the last two years he then he met with
Michael Cohen his staff what three times
more than ten hours he met with Glenn
Simpson with Fusion GPS and now he met
with this whistleblower and lied to the
American public every time they have
attempted a coup there's been one common
denominator the lies and deceit of Adam
Schiff he is now as you know a fact
witness and nowhere in our justice
system allows a fact witness to be the
prosecutor he needs to recuse himself
today and the speaker needs to remove
him as the chairman of one our most
sensitive committees that we have do not
get an Intel committee congressman Issa
she's not going to do that they're doing
the doing the dog and pony show today
about how well we want to work with the
president on us MCA and what oh of
course but we're gonna stand with the
founders and the Constitution she was
part of play this big game as I talked
about in the angle but oh well we'll
work with him but we're standing up for
the founding founding principles of this
country she's not gonna move all shift
from anything you know what she's also
doing she's not carrying it out in a
fair process every time that we've gone
through an impeachment we've had an
impeachment inquiry vote on the floor of
the house why do you have that because
it sets up the rules and it also
empowers the minority to also have
subpoena rights think about if you went
before a trial but you couldn't call any
witnesses this is exactly what she's
working through and you're supposed to
go through the Judiciary Committee
where does she go to Adam Schiff the
individual who has continued to lie he
lied on MSNBC he lied last Sunday when
he was asked does he know who the
whistleblower is he lied when he didn't
tell the Intel committee when he had two
opportunities when he had already met
this sounds a lot like the Cavanaugh
situation the same situation is building
of exactly what they're doing here hey
this just shows this is all political
yeah well his lawyer Marc Syed who's
represented Schumer and Hillary by the
way he put out a statement today that
boys'll blower statement of today saying
there was no contact between the legal
team in Congress until nearly a month
after the whistleblower complaint was
submitted to the Intel communities IG I
can unequivocally state that neither any
member of the legal team nor the
whistleblower has ever met or spoken
with congressman Schiff about this
matter
well what we find out in the New York
Times is a staffer of Schiff congressman
acted as the intermediary now why would
this need to go to Schiff
via a staffer before it became a matter
of public record why I think this Adam
Schiff needs to tell us what did he know
when did he know it and how many times
did he lie to us in the process and
you're going to tell me this staffer
never told the Chairman who who he was
didn't advise in the process and Schiff
didn't advise the staffer on the
direction because what did they tell
this whistleblower where to go to get an
attorney much like the person who came
forward against Kavanagh the exact same
pattern we have found before remember
what they wanted to do on the day the
president was being sworn into office
was the first day that the Democrats
talked about impeachment in print they
voted on it three times twice they voted
on impeaching this president before one
word ever came out from the Moller
report this has been political for day
one an atom shift has proven from this
point here he has no credibility
he has no credibility to be a chairman
and he has no right to be the prosecutor
in this case congressman are you
concerned as I laid out in the angle
that this impeachment obsession it's an
obsession
is having a you know a destabilizing
effect on our domestic policy and maybe
in ways that we don't even know yet our
foreign policy we have big issues with
North Korea big issues with China I mean
this is not exactly sending the to the
world a message of all is copacetic yeah
it's a presidential election but we're a
strong country this is in my view
sending a terrible signal to the rest of
the world it's doing a terrible signal
breaking the fabric of America democracy
itself was what they're trying to
discredit remember when they called this
out the speaker did not wait to have any
facts
she had her press conference at the
moment that all world leaders were
sitting in New York at a UN conference
why the president was going to meet with
other leaders thanked for a moment when
you think about foreign policy
what other foreign leader is going to
feel comfortable talking with now
they're never those cars are now united
states you they are not they're not only
know they're putting our foreign policy
and an in America in jeopardy down this
country congressman be be aware and I'm
sure you are
they want more transcripts they're not
stopping at this transcript
they want more transcripts of more
meetings of more conversations and I
certainly hope the the White House
counsel's office and and main justice
whoever is doing this that not happening
again because this is a terrible
precedent that was set necessary perhaps
in this case but a terrible precedent we
should never allow another one to go
forward for the sheer national security
of this country but this is a scam of
what they're moving forward this should
end this coup the second one they've
done because the common denominator is
the lies of Adam Schiff mr. minority
later thank you so much for being here
tonight we really appreciate it
thank you